كوريا الشماليه تحدي واضح وصارخ لاي
نداءات بوقف برامجها الصاروخيه وبين ما
تردد دول الغرب بصواريخ كوريا الشماليه
فالاخيره مستمره في مساعده
بعد ايام من اطلاق كوريا الشماليه صاروخين
بالستين متوسطين المدى فيما وصفته بانه
اختبار مهم لتطوير قمر صناعي للتجسس هي
الاحدث في عام شهيده سلسله من الاختبارات
الصاروخيه منها عبر للقارات في انتهاك
للعديد من قرارات مجلس الامن الدوليه
الامريكيا ووصفت تجربه الصاروخيه بالتهديد
للمنطقه
معتقد ان تجارب كوريا الصاروخيه تشكل
تهديدا للمنطقه والمجتمع الدولي ونؤكد ان
التزامنا بالدفاع عن كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان
واسطه التفاخر الكوري الشمالي بمنظومه
اقمارها الصناعيه الا ان خبراء اجانب
شككوا في ان تلك الانظمه التي اختبرتها
كوريا الشماليه قادره على العمل بشكل
طبيعي
من كوريا
التي استنكرت تلك التصريحات واكدت في رد
مضاد ابتسم بالتهديد المبطن ان المشككين
في قدرات صواريخ كوريا الشماليه سيعلمون
قريبا ما يمكن ان تفعله تلك الصواريخ
مشيره الى ان بلادها لا تخشى العقوبات ولن
يوقف ذلك برنامجها الصاروخي
[تصفيق]
في المقابل تحركات الامريكيه كوريه جنوبيه
من جهه جددت واشنطن عرضها للجوء الى
الوسائل الدبلوماسيه لحل الخلافات وهو عرض
لطالما رفضته كوريا الشماليه ومن جهه اخرى
تدريبات مشتركه ل واشنطن مع سول شملت نشره
قادفات ومقاتلات وفقما افادت وكاله رويترز
نقلا عن وكاله نيوز 1
روان حمزه العربيه